The word theory can be used to mean
something speculative and tentative in
everyday speech.
It probably usually is used in that
sense,
so I'll just very often use it in a much
more positive sense.
I think the easiest ways to use the
ordinary language word fact in the
ordinary language sense of the word fact
evolution is a fact.
The evidence that makes it a fat is
partly fossil evidence,
uh,
partly competitive comparative evidence,
looking at modern species and comparing
their bones,
their organs,
their structures generally and
especially their molecules that genes at
a molecular level.
This is extremely persuasive and
powerful evidence.
You compare the,
the genes of animals and plants.
You find that they,
the pattern of resemblance is a tree of
branching tree,
and that branching tree could only be a
family tree.
Other very persuasive evidence is there.
The geographical distribution of animals
and plants on islands and continents.
They are exactly where we should expect
them to be.
If evolution were a factor.